since President Trump took office
there's been a lot of rhetoric about
building a wall along the Mexican border
and imposing a high tariff on Mexican
goods well I was thinking I wanted to
take things anymore a positive direction
after all the beautiful thing about
television is there are no walls no such
thing so ladies dome and here's the plan
I'm going to head down to Mexico City
rent a television studio and shoot an
episode of our show with the help of an
all Mexican staff crew guests and studio
audience we're calling it conan Without
Borders made in Mexico
no border can contain the nonsense that
we perform on this show yes the
uselessness that we I'm that we waste
yeah I know our idiocy shared throughout
the war right well to get people in
Mexico excited about our show here's
what we're doing we're posting this
version of last night's monologue on our
team
cocoa website so that everyone can get
used to my comedic stylings south of the
border take a look starbuck siempre ha
sido el sitio para gente que no tiene no
- you gotta understand laptop I gente
can estado en webbing handles can be end
own solo Dion
[Laughter]
I don't know why you're a Japanese woman
but we'll forget it well figure just
always touch when someone understands
what I'm trying to do
again that's Conan without borders made
in Mexico our goal is to make a lot of
friends and it's airing Wednesday March
1st at 10:00 p.m. right here on TBS so
watch for that we'll be right
you